karim laghouag cavaliers de concours
complet et médaillé d'or aux jo de rio
nous ouvre les portes de ses écuries
percheronne mon voyage commence à nogent
le rotrou la capitale du perche est bien
connu pour le percheron cheval de trait
à la renommée internationale
c'est sur cette terre naturellement
équestre que karim laghouag me reçoit
c'est ici au coeur de ce domaine de 16
hectares que karim laghouag s'entraîne
pour sa participation aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo un cadre propice à
la réussite puisque ce dernier est déjà
champion olympique par équipes et
également médaillé d'or aux jeux
olympiques de rio allons voir comment il
se prépare sur cette carrière et
peut-être qu'il fera de moi le champion
de la montée à cheval
[Musique]
bonjour karine vous tombait à point
vous rejoignez ça va bien très bien
merci bonjour jerem bonjour en plein
entraînement sous le soleil c'est
formidable ici est ce que la compétition
a toujours été une évidence va pas
vraiment en fait je n'étais pas
compétitif ce que j'aimais c'était me
dépasser avec mon cheval essayer d'avoir
un lien ce qui est pas toujours cohérent
finalement au départ avec gagner ce
qu'il faut prendre tous les risques etc
moi je voulais pas prendre de risque et
ensuite c'est le regard des autres de
l'équipe mes proches des propriétaires
de chevaux et quand je gagne elle était
si heureux c'était tellement beau on
faisait la fête ça vous a stimulé ça
vous a donné envie de vous surpasser
c'est exactement ça après il faut
vraiment créer une symbiose une
complicité avec le cheval donc il faut
essayer d'avoir le le plus longtemps
possible
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai eu quand il
avait 4 ans donc s'il fait que c'est
maintenant il a 7 ans donc j'ai déjà
depuis un peu lors à 10 ans pour paris
est donc ici par exemple vous avez
toutes les lettres hawks ont disposé ses
délais de dressage pour faire des
figures imposées qui vont être jugés un
peu comme le patinage artistique alors
c'est l'une des étapes parce qu'il ya
d'autres étapes
au coeur de ce concours complet oui d'un
triathlon équestre où il ya du cross
également après le dressage bien sûr que
les dressages est essentiel puisque
c'est réussira à faire corps avec le
cheval pour lui demander tout et puis
après une partie qui est un peu plus
connus qui s'appelle le saut d'obstacles
où les bars tombe et ça fait des points
de pénalité il ya un temps imparti
également et vous vous avez un espace
entièrement dédié au saut d'obstacles
ici oui on a ici en bas la partie
dressage où on peut placer des obstacles
mobiles et sinon les obstacles de cross
fixe où on peut mettre aussi des
obstacles mobiles
c'est dans la partie haute qui est plus
accidenté en fait bien sûr vous m'y
emmener allez on y va la laisser partir
moi j'y vais papier quand même rassuré
moi je peux monter à cheval je vous ai
préparé un bolide à moi j'ai quand même
promis aux téléspectateurs vous allez
faire de moi le champion de la montée à
cheval celui exactement vous montrerez
tout à l'heure comme on le fait encore
un allez c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
alors vous savez karim vous avez préparé
le cheval qui va partir à tokyo et bien
pas tout à fait le cheval qui va partir
à tokyo et qui s'appelle triton fontaine
lui revient de compétition et ici nous
avons dream de viège qui est encore un
prétendant pour paris 2024 nous vous
avez une technique qui vous est propre
apparemment pour monter à cheval et le
montois en fait en sport études j'étais
en normandie au haras du pin et on
apprenait à monter comme ça et ça m'est
resté toute ma vie et qu'est ce que ça
donne moi je veux voir et bien voilà je
vais monter dessus si vous voulez donc
on a juste lentilles mans et rennes
on positionne une main sur le pommeau de
la salle l'autre n'a ici sur l'avant on
prend un petit appel de pied et à cheval
a donc vous vous ne mettez pas du tout
en fait les pieds sur les étriers et non
du côté gauche du côté droit en fait peu
importe côté gauche
parce qu'en fait les allées paix était à
gauche donc pouvoir monter il m'était
l'épée sur le côté voilà vous êtes super
athlétique parfait merci camille en tout
cas de nous accompagner aussi ok donc là
il a juste envie de recul et on a un
coût la vous lâche et puis vous écarter
la main vous venez par là c'est parti
voilà et pourquoi vous avez décidé en
fait finalement de vous lancer dans une
deuxième olympiade rio 2016 ça ne vous a
pas suffi disons que là la première
olympiade
personnellement j'aurais bien cesser mes
coaches m'ont dit mais t'as pas envie de
revivre ce que tu avec une deuxième fois
à j'ai dit allez on peut tenter
l'expérience
par contre j'ai besoin d'une préparation
bien bien différentes mais pourquoi
différentes comment vous avez vécu 2007
on a vécu cette olympiade avec une
certaine légèreté une insouciance un peu
la fleur au fusil
et maintenant c'est plus la première et
en plus on est attendu donc c'est une
préparation mentale physique qui est
totalement différent et une pression
finalement une certaine pression
exactement il est donc moi j'ai dit je
veux bien mais je vais avoir un peu plus
de moyens un peu plus de possibilité de
m'entraîner encore plus mais ça se
traduit comment concrètement là dans
votre quotidien en ce moment alors
concrètement cela se traduit surtout par
des nouveaux coaches qui sont venus en
plus des coachs un coup de physique pour
moi un coach mental que j'avais pas
avant un brio sur cette piste là sans
plus attendre on va vous voir vous
préparé avec ce deuxième cheval qui on
le rappelle ne vous suivra pas jusqu'à
tokyo
c'est parti je voulais travailler parce
que moi j'ai pas vous suivre
vous observez mais je m'arrêter là c'est
vraiment donné faut être raisonnable
[Musique]